do you smell it in the air it's a
comeback
that's right left go surging ready to
take down Sims each have $1,600 to bet
on for wild card games the minimum could
be 10 the maximum could be fifteen
hundred and seventy four choices one
winner the playoffs begin now Sims how
are you I'm doing good how are you I'm
good how are you I'm doing great hurry
what is your obsession that we can start
the podcast on a normal conversation
that we have to make the normal corny
intro it doesn't have to be corny what
you can't be talking over the intro
music that's a problem for editing says
me since I edited with Jake what what is
so hard well sit in the Edit Bay
together and I'll show you how it all
comes to me what do you have that'd if
we're having a nice conversation with
music because if you're cut off when I'm
not explaining this to you left go start
the podcast just start the pot you've
already started we're cut off and the
music's playing and the beat drops it
doesn't sound good it just doesn't work
why the random story I was gonna tell
was that we did our show
Chris Johnson was on he challenged he
believes that there's a conspiracy that
John Ross did not beat his point of time
before two for a I go on Twitter last
night and this guy that I guess is like
a publicity guy or the PR guy the PR guy
for the laser 40 times at the combine
was like this is not actually factually
correct we stand by our technology
something like that right and I was like
yeah I was like wait are you a
gatekeeper to like a laser 40 time
machine right because I would like to
just time my friends well I was like I
would like to have Sims run it anywhere
I was like I know tio and Ochocinco I'd
like them to do it I was like yeah but I
don't want to pay for it right
I want this publicity guy to give it to
me he goes I'm happy to come on your
program and just spell this conspiracy
theory and I was like because there's no
one I'd rather interview yeah and I was
like he our guy no no not only that [ __ ]
you
I want this conspiracy theory to live on
I think Chris Johnson beat it and I
don't want you to come in with your
facts ruin that well this Johnson ran
the
asked us for tea time in the history of
the world and the NFL Network lied
because it was the island year and John
Ross was not wearing the adidas and they
didn't want to give it to him and you're
like let's make history
I love that conspiracy theory and I'd
rather have that conspiracy theory exist
what you're saying John Ross he wasn't
wearing adidas so he didn't yeah I
remember it was the year the island if
you're wearing those Adidas shoes you
can win an island right and like he was
wearing Nikes Yeah right but I love that
conspiracy so that would add to the fact
that so they would give it to him though
just because it's not know it was in the
year where there was more attention
because of the island created news waves
for the fortuity from John Ross and I'm
just saying I sometimes want conspiracy
theories to possibly exist yeah I don't
need you coming in with your facts yeah
I mean and listen I believe that in in
about 15 years avocados will be proven
to be really bad for people yeah it's a
conspiracy theory yeah it's just a dumb
theory it's really not even conspiracy
you're right you're right yeah 20 years
be the issue is not with the laser to
Johnny laser man on the twittered yeah
it okay you're right it has nothing to
do with the laser a bold-faced lie it
means nothing no the biggest issue with
the 40 timing at the NFL combine it all
again goes back to human error and again
goes back to anything with the NFL they
want to save $7 on something because
they make 17 billion a year just like
NFL Jesus or NFL calm the digital mists
of that two sites is pitiful and that's
a digital missus holy as good as that's
as good I didn't get to tell you about
this it means my English is as good as
their damn web sites as far as when it
comes to digital quality I'll wait for
what was the human errors oh we did you
an error the 40 time getting to that is
that a human is in charge of the start
and that's the problem
so one guessing a play no it's not has
nothing to do with that now if you went
to a real place that was in a time and
really do it like the place I used to
work out at pari C's in New Jersey you
get in your position and you have a
thumb pad so then when your thumb comes
off that's the clock starts okay
so that's how you do it but now we're
course it does but the NFL has a guy
that just sits there and waits for you
to movements
so one time he could start an early one
time to get late on their website there
were sensors across a certain plane you
cross it well though there's a 10 a 20
what do you mean what are you talking
about I know that this is they start
with the hand time how many times you've
been a cowboy yeah more than you that's
actually right I want them to help him
do his addition this morning for his
bets and he's sitting there just cursing
out and I felt Jesus as he tries to
reload the schedule over and over again
well I know exactly what your problem
well my problem was I went on NFL Jesus
today and officially they always do this
on Thursday the default posts or they
don't impose yeah yeah default post yeah
now every time I go to schedules it
shows me the post season
yeah and it's another click I gotta do
it's another thing they've saved seven
cents on that no I'm talking about
normal yeah it's horrible it shouldn't
go to that I mean nobody wants to see
the post season schedule that doesn't
exist yet so that's stupid okay on their
part yeah okay good point Chris you're
right
no but no it doesn't matter it's stupid
it's stupid the other way you explain it
it's stupid and the real point is when
I'm on a full schedule and then you go
to try to go to a team specific schedule
it's back loads right and then you have
to press back again so it goes to the
schedule this is literally one percent
of our audience all right okay I just
want them to know the NFL cheaped out on
that tonight so how are we doing this
today so we talked about this on Monday
but just to recap all right so coming
out of week 17 Sims you are sitting at
590 bleacher bucks left go you are
sitting at 160 bleacher bucks and then
just in case you care records overall
for the year Sims you are 127 121 and 7
and let go you are 123 125 and 7 look
for games better than you and money
leader whoa all right so the way this is
gonna work today we'll do it like usual
only for games so we're gonna talk for
about 15 minutes on each I will give the
game and the line and the weather first
thing is this Antonio Brown was in our
building yesterday he dressed up in a
costume to avoid attention no that's I
don't think that's what it was there was
a show
it just aired last night called the
masked singer right and it's about
people that go up there with huge
elaborate masks on right and they sing
and then the judges have to guess who it
is
right and Antonio Brown apparently was a
contestant on that show I guess was in
hippopotamus outfit can you look and see
if he was on the show social I didn't
see didn't see but what about the show
show yeah they just type in the mail
either way he was on line to get a pass
to get in the building he was still
wearing his costume which tells you he
didn't want to be seen he was on the
show and he was going up to apparently
the 25th floor which is a CBS office
yeah did you hear the reports today
they're coming out a little bit a lot of
unnamed people are feeling that part of
the blow-up is the fact that juju Smith
Schuster was named team MVP Albert Bray
wrote that yeah right and I think
somebody else has corroborated that as
well what is the percentage what is the
percentage did you post online our take
that juju Zuma Shuster may be a better
wide receiver than Antonio Brown I mean
it was the title of the YouTube podcast
really is there any chance thanks
somehow Antonio Brown saw that he was
coming here and it alright so how are we
doing this okay so today it'll be pretty
much like usual I will give the game I
will give the line I will give the
weather I'll kick it over to Chris for
your full breakdown on the game left go
will come in with his thoughts on the
game and break it down give his bet and
then we can talk about it at the end for
longer than we normally do because we
don't have 16 games to get there oh I'm
not gonna interrupt you once oh whoa
helping out Henrique here
whoa during your section okay after I go
I can interrupt you as much as you want
alright so first game here guys at four
what time is the game on Saturday 425
first games at 12 435 435 on Saturday
the Indianapolis Colts visiting the
Houston Texans spread in this game for
us is Houston minus 1.5 it has moved to
two at some of the casinos weather
forecast for Houston do we care no
really sunny on Saturday 68 to the high
okay I'll let you know that's nice take
it away Christ comfortable day okay
Houston doesn't feel like a dome to me
no it's got it well it's a grass field
so that's what makes it feel a little
different right off the bat and it can
open up so it opens up it's not a true
dome yeah no but this the playing
surface is yeah it's different yeah it's
a great stadium that's the
first thing I'll say I don't think it's
the greatest advantage as far as
home-field advantage but I think the
first thing is this right this is where
I just let's start off at a base level
okay
the Houston Texans are oddly enough and
we don't think about this because I
think when we think about teams we just
go luck verse Watson right but the
Houston Texans have playoff experience I
mean they they have a lot of players on
their team who will played in playoff
football and in big-time games whether
it was the Houston Texans or some other
teams so they're not gonna be shocked
here the Colts on the other hand do not
really they have a few guys here and
there and you lock your ball sheer
there's a few here and there but I just
mean relatively I think they're the more
younger team not putting a whole lot of
stock into that either way but just
throwing that out there
I think the thing where we start is the
colts over the texans d and you've heard
me say this a lot during the week it's
this is one of the worst matchups for
the Houston Texans and the whole
playoffs I mean I really do believe that
it stinks that they got a deal with this
team because you know they have the
kryptonite to stop the great pass rush
of the Houston Texans and I think that's
the first thing I look at and you've
heard me say it a few times during the
week so I'm sorry too for you to have to
hear it for the third time but
regardless yes this is you know arguably
it's definitely one of the three best
old lines in football and it's
definitely one of the three best pass
four technical lines in football right
and that's where I worry about the
Houston Texans it's one of the worst
pass defenses with the Houston Texans
they don't have great man-to-man corners
it will be important for Jonathan Joseph
to be back playing better this week or a
hundred percent healthy I should say the
other thing I would say with the Houston
Texans
I wish there would be a little more bass
and simple on their coverages they go
for the kill too much right left go
where they go like all we got him in
third and nine let's make it fourth and
22 and I want to just go let's just make
it fourth and two and make a punt I was
just gonna add so for a lot of these
games I went back and watched a ton of
the highlight yeah great like full
package here the amount of times that I
saw Houston bringing two defenders like
extra defenders are three in like third
and whatever yeah it was like every time
I watched I came yeah it's they're
bringing two linebackers or a linebacker
and a safety they just sell out all that
they do too many dumb are over
aggressive things and bigs
tuitions that allow them to be burned I
mean just whether it goes back to your
Eagles game with a set 90 yard bomb over
Tyrell Matthews head to Nelson Aguilar
and they have what clowny reader covet I
don't the one team that doesn't need to
do they don't need to do it exactly
right and they don't even really need to
do some of these like you know intricate
coverages that they do at times where I
just go there's just no need just play
basic you're talented enough and good
enough to not have to take those chances
so the big thing is yes can they get
past pressure the one thing I'll look up
with the pass pressure I think this is
one thing for all viewers to watch out
for and it was a little bit of an issue
or it could be an issue this game is
it's Braden Smith against JJ Watt and
pass protection okay I just not heard a
negative thing about Braden Smith oh
yeah it's pretty talented but well it's
just a rookie okay who's got to deal
with a guy who's a very well schooled
pass rusher who gave Gabe Braden Smith a
few issues the first time they heard
that the first time the second time they
played a few weeks ago what was that
four or five weeks ago now fort week 14
so there so there is one thing I do look
at and I would expect the Colts in
certain situations when they have a
feel-good field to go oh they're only
rushing for and it's JJ Watt matched up
against Braden Smith that they will do
something to just help him out a little
bit whether it's just slide guys that
way or have a back chip but at the end
of the day uh you know JJ Watts not the
guy that I think can rule in the game
the x-factor for the Colts Texans
defense is Jadeveon Clowney I will say
that and I will always stand by that
because Jadeveon Clowney can have zero
tackles zero pressures and zero
nothing's in the game and be the most
disruptive player on the field and
everybody else has the stats but he
ruined like 70% of the place he's the
guy I look at to go he could be the one
that goes above and beyond and can
really make this a mess if he plays
extraordinary I don't expect that to
happen because I think that Colts
offense is pretty damn good and I'm
worried about luck having all day long
to throw the ball and just striking deep
with what we talked about a little bit
yesterday's a little bit of an
underrated receiving quarry and we all
talk about T Y Hilton but AE Braun's
good the other tight ends are pretty
solid okay and then you get into the
chester Rogers and the Dontrelle in
mentor or survival
sir serviceable targets especially
against a secondary like the Houston
Texans now flipping it over to the other
side of the ball I don't expect the
Houston Texans to be able to run the
football I don't and I do think you
there is the possibility to run the ball
on the Indianapolis Colts for some teams
but the Texas just are not good enough
up front to do it I think what are the
teams that are either well I think it is
the big hulking physical like a team
like a team like the Tennessee Titans if
they didn't get into the game they got
in last week I do think eventually if
that game could have just stayed close
and they could have stayed with it
you're gonna bust a run just like I told
you with the Dallas Cowboys the Dallas
Cowboys Ezekiel I ran the ball 17 times
for 85 yards like he was having a
successful day they just fell down
because they missed some fourth and ones
and luck he'll do that and what we write
and remember they're the Cowboys messed
up some fourth and twos and they had the
field long so they fell behind and then
couldn't really stay consistent with the
run either but I don't either either way
all I'm saying is I don't think the
Texans will be able to run the on the
ball and the Colts period bar none now
the secondary for the Colts is solid
it's nothing special I like them but
they are going to have to do something
in my opinion special to stop DeAndre
Hopkins you know a they don't have to
double them but you have to do something
we're okay if you're gonna play zone
defense and do all of that and have the
corner play over the top then you better
have a linebacker always flying out
underneath to stop some back shoulders
or the hitch routes or anything like
that I'll go with something when my dad
said yesterday and are in our breakdown
podcast a little bit I think that rut
runs true to the one thing I worry about
with the Colts defense against the
Texans is like my dad said what do you
say chasing cars or whatever I do worry
about that with the Colts defense they
are a little over aggressive at times
they're young that was what I was gonna
they want to attack the football right
they want to go after so that will be
something I look at to to go okay the
first time you know Watson fakes the
ball to Lamar Miller is he gonna come
out the back side and the bootleg and be
totally scot-free and they're gonna be
like whoa holy crap he kept the ball and
then there's gonna be a cross or running
free those are the little things I worry
about
and then I also worry about the x factor
which is the Shawn Watson you know again
to echo something my dad said again
yesterday I'm gonna say it again because
it's true is yeah deshaun Watson could
get sacked ten times in this game but he
could also on those ten possible sacks
only get sacked twice and make eight
amazing place and when we go damn they
won the game they were outplayed and
they had him bottled up but he broke
four tackles and made seven spin moves
on those plays where they should have
had sacks and he threw for 200 yards in
those plays I feel the same way about
luck
yeah there's certainly I get that uh so
that's uh that would be the big thing to
me just on that side of the ball but I
think that's a fairly even matchup and I
will say this to add to that one one
more thing about the Watson thing I do
think that Shawn Watson will have a hard
time scrambling though as long as
they're not too far out of position I
really do
that one thing about the Colts is
they're fast and they're exactly right
all their D lineman can run they like
even just like looking at de Nikko
Audrey's body yes I'm like well
put-together no doubt about he's more of
like a DN they play a DTAC Marcus hunt
right is is like an extra in Game of
Thrones and I look at him and I go where
is he put in 300 yeah I know it's like
in his arms and his shoulders it's like
well displaced yeah but they all have
good legs they all have good legs on
Ridgeway we know about right sheared can
run you know you got your Kimiko to
raise you got your Tai Kuan Louise know
about maniac you got your yeah Darius
Leonard is sitting there go exactly I'm
eating dish on Watson's bone I feel the
same thing with Neil Walker there's a
Neil Walker or whatever it's wall Paul
Walker number of discs II know it's not
all right P part okay
but number 50 Walker I'm blanking on his
first name but I know he's 15 I know
it's Walker I think you're wrong I want
to say Neil I don't know why but either
way guy it's just a step slower than
Darius Leonard Anthony Anthony there it
is Tony walk only eight Tony Tony Walker
but um yes so those are the things that
I think are intriguing to me about the
matchup overall I'm gonna wrap it up I'm
making my pick here right and yeah we're
making your pick okay so um let me just
make sure okay I am putting 500 Wow and
$80 an 80 yes 580
on the Indianapolis Colts Wow
yep I think the Indianapolis Colts are
going to win this game 31 to 27 and the
game is about I you know I don't even
know who I'm room for I think I'm
rooting for the Houston Texans just so
everybody knows out there I'm just gonna
tell you I think I am just because I
like to Shawn Watson I like Billy
O'Brien I don't know I don't know if I'm
definitely rooting for them but I feel
like I am but this is a horrible matchup
I never know until a game comes on you
know that so you do have a vested horse
in this game then I don't know if I do I
playoff games are weird to me I got
invested horse I can go into a game and
go I'm rooting for this team in a game
start and I go I'm not rooting for them
I don't know why but I'm solely based on
who I bet on yeah okay so I'm gonna give
you like my stream of consciousness yeah
kind of just wrote down everything as I
was going through how I pick games right
so the first thing I did was look at by
the way I heard that you said this
before youth believe that if the Texans
can sack in yeah four times I say four
times or more then that bodes well that
they can win the football so I looked it
up the game the Texans beat the Colts
this year yeah I sacked him four times
right again they lost they sacked him
too yeah just a little funny I totally I
pull those numbers out of my ass you
know okay oh right old times that's what
I mean because it was just a rough
estimate of the first thing I wanted to
do was go I looked at the last game yeah
damn
Tiwa Hilton had 199 yards and no
touchdowns do you know how much you have
to beat a team's ass and not score and
get a hundred ninety nine yards that was
incredible
also the Colts had five sacks in that
last game and I looked I went wow
DeAndre Hopkins
deshaun Watson tried to get it to him
ten times and he only caught four right
and I said how does Hopkins do against
the Colts because sometimes receivers
have big games against other teams yeah
we learned that this year with AJ Green
against the Ravens sure when AJ Green
plays the Ravens big things happen and I
also wanted to know Sims always says
team should double team what the Hopkins
let's see how the Colts do right in the
11 games Hopkins has faced the Colts
he's only had two games of a hundred or
more yards
in those 11 games he's only scored three
touchdowns right they were in the last
three
so overall the Colts yeah in the Texans
every year twice a year seems to hold
Hopkins in check which is a very good
thing the games in Houston though never
forget that Houston in that week 14 game
really dominated the first 22 minutes
and you look back and then they let up
17 straight points right T Y Hilton is a
huge problem for Houston he's a little
bit banged up right now but I don't
believe there's anyone in the Texans
that can run at the gear that T Y Hilton
can right when you watch him play
Jonathan Joseph can't catch him Kareem
Jackson can't catch him and Tyra
Matthews always kind of one step behind
him I went back and looked T Y Hilton
has played about a hundred and eighty
games in his NFL career of the top four
performances in terms of receiving yards
three of them are not just against
Houston they were in Houston 2018 this
past this year nine catches 199 yards
last year five catches a hundred and
seventy five yards and two touchdowns
and by the way the quarterback was
Jacoby pre-set that game and 2014 nine
catches 223 yards and one touchdown
here's what's wild in 2013 he went seven
for 121 and three in Houston 2015 and
went five for 88 with Matt Hasselbeck as
his quarterback and then in 2012 three
for 78 and one touchdown he's really
never had a bad performance right in
Houston he always goes off it's a
matchup thing
Houston's offense the last time they
played let the defense down a number of
times the defense get stops and stops
but you can't keep hoping for your
defense to stop Andrew Luck now and
Houston's offense being basic every I
went back and watched three Houston
games
it's either wide receiver screens to
Hopkins or Demaryius and hoping they
break something off it's either a deep
ball on the sidelines of Hopkins and
just going 50/50 or it's I really hit
Lamar Miller hits a gap right I really
hope the Laura Miller head yeah that's
right and that's the
whole offense or Watson running around
this is just making a play happen but
you're right that's the whole offense
and and I didn't get to this point just
and I don't mean to interrupt you but
I'm doing well [ __ ] off okay I owe you
your you're up in that department like
9,000 to four but the that is a part
that I think is interesting you said
about how they get the ball what they do
on offense and especially the Hopkins
part right it's down the sidelines or a
back shoulder contested throw the Colts
corners even though they're not great
they're solid the one thing they have is
size and strength and everything except
the kid 27 which I always blank on his
name I got here two or no it's 23 its
Kenny Moore other than him the other
guys have great size and physical
strength so Hopkins can't necessarily
dominate them at the line of scrimmage
like he can most corners I make sure
helped though I also look at this game
yeah and this the last time they played
Indianapolis jumped on the lead
Houston started making a comeback
because I wrote this down in all capital
letters no matter what is going on in a
game deshaun Watson can bring you back
yeah it is incredible he takes one step
and I looked at the score and they were
down ten and they're right back in it
right
the thing is though this was the game
where Jadeveon Clowney jumped offsides
we're sitting at two minutes left it's
third and four
Andrew Luck is under Center and he gets
clowny to jump right because in my mind
that's the game that we're gonna have on
Saturday yeah in a crucial time of the
game will Watt and clowny get to luck
and so the fact that the last game he
got bit for offsides
clowny is gonna be more motivated than
ever I would because if that ball got
back into Sean Watson's hands I had a
lot of confidence they were gonna score
sure I forgot because I didn't really
watch that game I went back and watched
Texans Jaguars and I went damn bortles
even had a few opportunities to beat
them deep in that game no doubt about it
like and he just missed them he really
did yep also at the end of that game
Watson converted four straight third
downs to waste
six minutes in that game so they were
operating in a very high level just in
terms of their offense and being
comfortable good tight end usage and all
that stuff it came down to this
statistic though that blew me away
yeah Andrew Luck this entire season has
been sacked 18 times right in the last
four weeks
deshaun Watson has been sacked 21 times
right in the end I have more confidence
that the Colts are gonna win this game
I have more confidence in the coach I
have a lot of confidence in eibar flu
looking at the Texans offense and
deducing it down to what it is
I have the Colts winning 31 to 39 $10 on
the call time on the other random
factoid that I have from this game yeah
there are seven teams in the NFL whose
cities the first letter is shared by
nobody Atlanta shares a with Arizona
Philadelphia shares P with Pittsburgh do
not pull up the team right now there are
seven teams right two of them are
outliers Oakland shares their o with
nobody Washington shares their no with
shares their W with nobody but there are
five letters right in the middle all
next to each other that are all
individuals g IH g h i j k how do you
know Green Bay Houston in D Jacksonville
Kansas City they're the only five
they're all next to each other and I
always think when those teams play each
other it's a great battle Houston Indy H
versus I the Battle of the alphabet
I had a daddy cigar when I made my picks
can you tell I said they're looking at
NFL Jesus and mean like what do you know
their neighbors Houston in it right in
the middle the alphabet deep dive very
deep yes
out of left Cofield super anything else
on this game before we move on no um I I
am gonna say this yeah you have 580 on
India I know who I'm rooting for
yeah I'm rooting for the Houston Texans
right the Houston Texans
because the the true thing is the reason
that
I only put $10 on this game yeah is at
home deshaun Watson right a veteran team
like you said having already lost to
that team at that place and also man I
just the the the JJ Watt Jadeveon
Clowney [ __ ] but oh I I really like the
Colts do you want to do your two quick
questions before we move on know what
scares you the most right about your
Beck
Oh about my pick deshaun Watson and what
in the end convinced you you know what
no I'm still going with this pick the
Eber Phyllis Frank Reich factor I just
think they're just I'm gonna give them
the edge on both sides where I just go
I'm I like what they do on that side of
the ball game planning wise I'm always
excited to see what Frank Reich's gonna
do like with his approach on a weekly
basis I would say ever since about the
midway point of the year I was like oh
damn I mean I found it fun as a txt
quarterback to watch Frank cuz I was
like they always got like five or six
like aggressive throws down the field
and they find a cool way to do it
whether it's formation or you know a
design that I haven't seen whatever it
is those are the things I think that put
me over the edge what is really funny is
let me ask you both this is a media
effort here I feel less at some point
feel less confident about my Colts yes
well I worry about any of them because I
just I yeah there's just they're not a
perfect team but I have a question and I
have two questions my media NFL question
is a lot of people when they're on TV or
they're talking about their picks will
go well you know I picked Houston as my
Super Bowl team so I gotta have him
winning this game yeah picked as my
Super Bowl team I did not pick Houston
no good was I supposed to know now oh
right you picked this week when you hear
someone do that what do you think about
them as a broadcaster Super Bowl picks
preseason are dumb I think they're I
don't know it's kind of kind of being
like you know I was pretty smart four
months ago right and a whole lot shits
changed in those four months I just and
I feel like any time I watch a CBS Fox
like any of those they're like well you
know I made this decision four months
stand by it yeah that's a way to go
through and then I cannot remember my
other question okay so moving on 8:15
Saturday night the Seattle Seahawks
visiting the Dallas Cowboys read in this
game is Dallas minus 1.5 weather in
Dallas on Saturday 66 and sunny 66 and
sunny ok dad do they open their roof
there or that doesn't open no it does it
does open yeah
it's weather could be a factor so they
can put the hole in the roof on the top
so Jesus and God could see would you on
Saturday or would you keep it closed if
you were facing the Seahawks near the
Cowboys that's 66 out I would do
whatever makes the stadium loudest then
I would close the top yes right so
that's probably what I would that was a
good answer
Thanks I'm sitting there going I wonder
if dak likes a little breeze back ya
know if I'm there the Cowboys I'm just
going I want it to be loud I've never
been to that stadium your life no no
I've never been have been difficult I
know I knew and I kind of just missed it
on my way out and you know the game that
I saw there what the my first time makes
force experience there was Texas
Nebraska big 12 championship game call
McCoy throwing it out in dama can sue
gets four and a half sacks and seven
tackles for loss four and a half sacks
in one game it was incredible and then
Colt McCoy threw it out and it hit a
railing
yeah and that gave them enough time for
the field oh that wasn't I remember the
field goal kickers name wasn't Tucker
but he hit it was the not Tucker it was
not talking are you sure
are you sure are we sure I'm almost
positive damn I was because I picked it
up yeah I was in Nebraska
Seahawks Cowboys bring it down are you
gonna tell us who the kicker was uh yeah
I'm looking it up okay 2009 kicker I
feel like it was let's see Hunter
Lawrence and good job lefke I'll tell
you what though Hunter Lawrence that kid
was born to kick at Texas I'd bet you
his hair swooped to the side that's most
most southern schools nice puffy vest
and are those boat shoes oh man okay
alright you done now yeah all right got
a gingham shirt under that vest
is that it's like a that does it's like
a box it's pretty much like the shirt
Josh is wearing all right Dallas Dallas
Cowboys here we go Seattle Seahawks okay
here we go
um alright let's go I think the the
thing I would start off with is the
Seattle defense versus the Cowboys
offense um I think the first thing is
this I would start by saying this and
the thing that I would like that I do
think that Dallas is going to play this
way I think this is the reason you've
heard me say it I think this is why we
saw dak Prescott play last week and
their offense do what they do because I
think they're trying to build on their
pass game which has had some success as
of late so I would be shocked if the
Dallas Cowboys just came out and we're
like here Zeke Ronan in the middle I
mean this is the Seattle Seahawks and
Pete Carroll he's old-school his first
thing is all week gonna be stop zekiel
stop easy we're gonna stop the run we're
gonna put eight people by the latch
company they're gonna be foaming out the
math for that Ana's eql it's also made
comments during the week that he expects
his heaviest workload of the year and he
feels as good as he's felt all year and
the old line a few of them have said
things like that so just from that base
premises I do think that Dallas realizes
too that if they want to go to the Super
Bowl they do need that passing element
and they no longer can have this
old-school dak Prescott quarterback
approach of just you know running on
first running on a second bail us out on
third so I think they'll find a way to
boo legs play-action screens cheap ways
to get him completions to get him going
early on okay I look at the Seahawks
defense and there's a lot of good and
everything in Seattle is going the right
way
but there's just a lot of solid and good
I just would hope everybody knows that
there's things that are promising for
the future but the only really two above
average things in the Seattle Seahawks
defense where I would go it's past
really good in this special it's two
players I was gonna say yeah linebacker
right Wagner and Frank Clark those are
the two guys that are the true
difference makers you know Geron reads a
fine player don't get me wrong
Tedric Thompson at safety I don't even
sure of his health status right yeah
good not the player he once was but
still good
pune fort yeah moments but still not
where I'm gonna go a Frank Clark and
Wagner can take over it they they can
make place to change a football game so
yeah I look at it that way
but I do think at the end of the day
that would debt with Seattle's defense
and the way they play on the road okay
that's concerning cuz that's a real
thing and the fact that you know a lot
of the prime Dallas starters and their
old line Ezekiel Adar gonna be healthy I
do think Dallas is gonna be able to run
the ball on the Seattle Seahawks I would
be shocked really you know you know my
thought on as this is already I just
look at these teams they're very similar
they do want to win the battle up front
I understand all of that but I also look
into the fact of where we've heard the
thing about dak Prescott right oh
they're only good against a man-to-man
and we've talked about that a little bit
well a lot of the times I do think
Seattle's past defense plays into the
hands of Dallas because a lot of the
times it ends up playing like man-to-man
even though it's zone you can get
certain concepts that play man-to-man
and I think that favors Dallas and what
they go against as well is it fair to
say that in the cover 3 because the
corners drop back and their backs face
the corner quarterback yeah there's
opportunities for a lot of back
shoulders there definitely is it depends
how they play if they play the cover
three the true way they've been mixing
it out late been mixing it up that if
they played the true way their backs
should always be turned to the sidelines
and then I can see the quarterbacks
right but they will play some man-to-man
but their corners they're just they're
average guys they're nothing like their
safeties Hill is now on IR delano Hill
is right so they're beat up that they
are beat up right okay so I just look at
that and that's a little concerning to
me with Seattle's defense which let's
not they have not been extraordinary I
mean I don't know you know last week
they let up points just Kansas City
scored points the 49ers beat them by
three and scored 26 on them I know they
had a good showing against Minnesota the
week before that and it looks on paper
like they had a good showing the week
before that against San Francisco at
home when they won 43 to 16 and I
promise you everybody out there that the
49ers moved the ball up and down the
field on Seattle and just messed up
certain situations or fumbled or turned
it over or missed a field goal or drop
the punt it was all those type of things
but that's that side of the ball and
then when I flip it over to the other
side of the ball you know this is what
the first thing I worry about here in
this game I mean you're gonna see the
Dallas Cowboys New Orleans Saints
defense that's who you're gonna see
you're gonna see that [ __ ] crazed
[ __ ] going crazy foaming at the
mouth you're gonna see that for the next
three weeks out of the Dallas defense
there's just at least one week yeah I
think you're gonna see it all three
weeks now I'm not saying they can win
those games all weeks but they will be
after this Cowboys are going well no I
mean just if they if that happened they
can they can get to a championship
scramble Cowboys will be crazy
[ __ ] crazy MF run to Super Bowl
for the next three weeks they do they do
scare me they're okay we know that the
Seahawks want to run the football and
and do that style of football game but I
just don't see them being able to run
successfully on the Dallas Cowboys
throughout the game they might have a
few here and there because they do have
some size advantages you know when if
they can get Dallas in the pass rushing
a line or the smaller unit that's on the
field but at the end of the day too if
that happens I don't worry for Dallas
because Dallas has to go man-to-man and
play the Seattle offense man-to-man they
can do it they can do it enough if they
feel compromised in the run they can do
it all game long if they want to this
Dallas secondary is really good and the
Seahawks receivers are good but not
great
and their offensive pass team is just
good not great so I don't even know I
don't think they have enough to expose
Dallas if they played too much man okay
now the other thing I would say this the
Seattle pass protection is still not
great it's not it's nothing special and
that scares me and they try to do their
best to not really have them to be in
that type of football game where he
drops back a lot and does that I do
think Dallas is going to get pressure on
him throughout the game and I think
they'll be able to do it with four and I
also think that Russell Wilson who does
not scramble as much this year as in
years past I think even if he scrambles
in this game it's it's gonna be tough
sliding there's just too much speed in
the front seven of the Dallas Cowboys
those two linebackers and they play zone
a lot but even if they play man they're
gonna have somebody there watching
Russell Wilson they are
we're going to run Russell Wilson down I
mean van Dhiresh and Jaylon Smith will
chase him down and I do think the guys
in the edge can chase him down with us a
Randy Gregory DeMarcus Lawrence and
those kind of guys now where I do worry
about it is Dallas is so freaking crazy
and kamikaze at times that they do fall
out of pass rush lanes and do [ __ ] like
that and then all of a sudden you go
there's Russell Wilson you just stepped
up in the pocket and he ran for 35 yards
and that's all he did because you know
some guy was just like I gonna get the
sack Rod Marinelli yelling at me that's
what I worry about with Dallas cuz
they're like a bunch of you know
meatheads that way um but I think let me
just look at my notes to make sure I
didn't miss anything here that I wanted
to talk about but I think at the end of
the day again my base thought goes back
to this they are similar teams they are
really based on the same principles beat
you up up front let's be sound let's not
mess it up let's let the other team mess
it up let's hustle to the football and
know our details except there's one team
at home and there's one team that I
believe is head and shoulders more
talented than the other
okay left go and because of that I am
going $1,000 on the Dallas Cowboys
because I believe this may be the
biggest point spread of the Dallas
Cowboys
we got the lair Longhorns won the other
night now we can go here galas on ya
let's go down cowboy how about them
Cowboys but okay I'm gonna pick a 27 to
17 I have one question for you did the
notion that you're picking deckhand
Jason Garrett over Russell Wilson and
yeah Pete Carroll into your brain
definitely scared me it was the only
thing that scared me in this match that
scares me
along with like I told you the pass rush
moving out of their lanes and Russell so
if you ask me two things because I would
say to you that the thing that scares me
the most is Seattle's playoff experience
yes I get and their their willingness to
bootleg and roll him out could have huge
like I'm just envisioning Tyler Lockett
scoring right I don't worry about them
being out of position on those type of
plays I'm more worried about the true
drop back pass and all of a sudden the
DN who's supposed to come around the
aaron's fly line inside and awesome they
got two guys in the B gap and then then
Russell Wilson just like makes one move
and he's like nobody's here I'm gone
guys and Russell Wilson does that run
where he's not really that fast but he
still gets play you're like yeah I still
got 35 yards right he runs like a Mario
character yes yeah okay let me go
through I went back and I rewatched week
three right so Seattle's Owen to Dallas
as one in one it was like looking back
at weight loss before photos right where
you're like this person doesn't exist
like the Cowboys offense was so bad and
had no identity right and two high
ranking weapons for the teams were
Brandon Marshall and young the art out
Tavon Austin bright like those were the
two big weapons for the opposite time
Ezekiel that was still playing himself
into game shape Earl Thomas had two
insane interceptions the one to seal the
game and one in the beginning that he
caught on his foot I was amazing right
that person doesn't exist at yeah so it
was very funny to go back and watch Zeke
stepped out on a huge touchdown where he
just went up the sideline yeah the D the
next drive led up this huge touchdown
the Tyler Lockett on a bad assignment
they're down 14 to 3 and then at the end
of the half Randy Gregory punches a guy
in the face setting
the sea bass field goal so Dallas was
down 17 to 3 which is the worst possible
start possible in a matchup between two
similar teams so I'm actually gonna
yield a little bit of my time to ask you
a question yeah in a game in which time
of possession and setting the tone is
the most important thing how do you
figure out in your mind who's going to
set the tone yeah when you're looking at
a game like this yeah cuz that's my big
question and I don't know how to do it
exactly right and I said them and yours
was Dallas is gonna come out like he's
at home so they had the crowd to do that
and I do believe they are a notch above
Seattle like Talan why that was my big
questions I would hang my hat unto go I
think they can impose their will on the
other team because as Dallas was making
a comeback
Seattle spread out Dallas in the second
half and kind of diced him up quick
throws across the middle on the outside
Doug Baldwin and then power runs up the
middle right and I saw that about ooh
that's the way that Seattle could attack
this Dallas defense it's the way the
better offenses have spread them out and
kind of outside all that stuff Zeke had
a huge run at the end of that game and
fumbled it he had like 150 yards and he
didn't have a good game right he could
have destroyed that team I went back and
I looked at Seattle's last game against
Arizona or I didn't get to watch the guy
I wanted to see how it went huh you know
what I saw right I saw Russell Wilson
get sacked six times I saw their special
teams get blown up like to punt blocks
like a number of other special teams
issues but Russell Wilson got sacked
6-times
yeah and this is a much less athletic
defensive line at least in Dallas yes
not as deep so good any of it so then I
went well how is Russell Wilson done
against Dallas let me just check that
out yeah sure the record looks good
yeah 4 and 1/2 and OH in Dallas the one
game the one game that he lost he had 93
passing yards with who touched when
Oromo that was about 2014 in the five
games against Dallas yeah Russell Wilson
has never thrown for over
210 yards in any game so it's never been
a big Russell Wilson performance then I
went and looked well how has dak done in
Seattle everyone tells me he's really
bad against Owen
dak against Seattle is Owen too one of
those games was in Dallas one of those
games was in see how its right a game in
Seattle this year he went 168 one
touchdown two interceptions again awful
game flow for dak yes you like down 17
to 3 it's the worst game I gotta leave
town and he wasn't playing good at that
point the other game was 2017 in Dallas
he threw for 188 181 no touchdowns two
interceptions not a great game let me go
back and check that game out watch that
game 2017 game it was week 16 right both
teams were eight and six so this was
last year fighting for the playoffs both
finished nine and seven right neither
team made the playoffs but this was a
game with a lot of Elijah in Dallas
maybe I can glean something from it if
you remember this game yeah Dallas
starts the game dominating early with
four minutes left in the second quarter
they're up six nothing but they've
dominated the game yeah
Dez Bryant fumbles Seattle goes get some
points dak throws a very bad pick six in
which he kind of floats it over the
defender the corner jumps into the
Salvation Army bucket via his other
interception was just a deflection off a
wide receiver but I looked at that team
and I went see that looked like the
Dallas offense that I saw in Week three
that's not the same one it was Zeke
coming off his suspension and all that
stuff Columbo is the old line coach
Dallas settles for four field goals in
that game that was also when I believe
the beginning of the end for their field
goal kicker they cut he missed that
crucial fifth field goal to bring them
within but either way I went this one
felt a little misleading too but I like
that Dallas jumped all over him early I
asked myself how does Russ do in wild
car - Wade games because how many wild
card away games has he played - well
he's had set he's had on I'm just
guessing in playoff games yeah Russell
Elson is five and Oh at home right he's
two and three on the road in his two
wild card away games
they beat the Vikings ten now on the
missed field goal yes where Russell
Wilson really didn't do anything all
games right and the defense really got
him there right and the other one was
the win in Washington oh that's right
which I believe was the rg3 injury game
um it was you're exactly right
it was didn't play that great didn't
really bad right didn't play that great
right no this is the end then the next
week they went to Atlanta and lost there
and then I thought okay well look
Seattle's much better at home their last
five games four of them have been at
home they haven't even been on the road
a lot in the last few weeks and then the
one thing that no one's talking about
and you popped into my head
DAC in the playoffs when Dallas played
Green Bay Dallas was coming off of a bye
it was Dallas his only playoff game that
year yeah dak Prescott in his only
playoff game threw for three hundred and
two yards three touchdowns and one
interception yeah an amazing game and
you know why you popped into my head
because when Aaron Rodgers threw that
pass to Jared Cook we were watching that
game in this [ __ ] office and you went
dak had an amazing game and no one will
remember it you said no one will
remember it well I'm [ __ ] remember it
mm-hmm
I have the Dallas Cowboys winning this
game and I'm putting 1500 and [ __ ] $70
that's so crazy
what would have happened what would have
happened did you see can I tell you the
best part about that whole thing yeah
was when you made your pick Josh was
looking at me I said I know what's
coming and I sold it didn't you sold it
really nice job buddy the the makes me
feel good it takes the pressure off me
in that game puts all the pressure on
the Colts it does the fact that I'm
getting but do you know what's crazy is
like it's the only game I felt
comfortable and
and this is what's crazy to me let me
just wrap it up really quick it's scary
because I have lost a lot of these bets
over the years betting against the
Seahawks in the playoffs yeah
the Detroit game comes to mind right
away right where we thought Detroit was
gonna go up there and beat him but I
felt confident because the game is in
Dallas and that's the big thing what
scared me about this is I looked it up
the Giants this season when allowing a
hundred or more rushing yards excuse me
the Cowboys this season when allowing a
hundred or more rushing yards are one in
five mmm they're one win was last week
against the Giants okay and so I'm a
little bit worried it's the reason I
asked you this question in the beginning
is I believe if Dallas can set the tone
which is what didn't happen earlier this
year they didn't score enough points in
their big 86 game last year if they can
set the tone and Russell Wilson has to
run around with that d-line I'm gonna be
at home sitting back feeling great but
if Dallas gets down 14 nothing I'm
freaking out man of course you are I
mean if that happens then their only way
to win is gonna be by like one point I
just I felt a lot of confidence with
Amari Cooper against this banged up
secondary I felt really good that Zeke
was the one getting the rest I felt
really good that when I looked at
Seattle's defense they didn't travel
well in the road I get very concerned
that I believe the three-headed monster
of Pete Carroll Wasel Russell Wilson and
you're gonna say I'm crazy Michael Dixon
is amazing for a matchup like this I
guess you have a coach that's willing to
risk it all against the coach and Jason
Garrett that plays sometimes like he's
scared you have a quarterback in Russell
Wilson that's not gonna force it and can
make magic and dak we haven't seen him
in this situation a lot and when I think
about Michael Dixon and pinning dak back
that scares me
yeah and that's my fear I get you I was
in the shower with no music on going
well no the funny thing is as I was very
close to going 1580 on the Dallas
Cowboys 70 I mean yeah I mean
there was when we walked back well I
mean I almost feel like I still want to
change it I'm almost so I got to lay
down oh can I tell you why I did my
strategy yet you have a $400 lead on me
right I figured you might go 400 across
the board and you did that first bed I
went [ __ ] because I need some of the
craziness to happen right I need to load
up so really what it comes down to right
now is go Texans and go Cowboys you know
weird way you got a root against the
Cowboys yeah I don't have to I mean if
my first game comes out there when you
hit both we're right back where we
started
okay but you're right if it goes the
other way then I'm I'm going to root for
the Cowboys to win by one plus it's
actually a really good betting situation
for me I'm actually kind of covered but
all right guys yeah you are you're
moving on that felt good you are good
you're are coming it's funny that we
thought the same thing and I think most
people are gonna chicken out on that bet
during the game or during the week and
that's the one I looked at and I hope
what the hell do I know about betting
anyways I'm just saying no but I think I
think I'll make you look like you want
to chicken out
but there's one team that's clearly
better than the other in my opinion and
what was a line we got on that one and a
half one and a half whoa oh and my score
what was your score I only did twenty
three to twenty I pick twenty seven
seventeen I have 23 13 with like the
famous Russell Wilson touchdown with 115
leg and without getting the kickoff on
site I hear you
alright guys moving on next game here
Sunday at 1:05 the Los Angeles chargers
on the road visiting the Baltimore
Ravens this game is Baltimore two and a
half and whether in Baltimore on Sunday
Chris 52 and sunny
52 and sunny that's good for that LA in
Baltimore that's fine I mean man 52
that's as good as they pour right there
what the hell
climate change is an issue in the
playoffs you know what's funny too is I
think I do my [ __ ]
ya know go ahead say it what you want to
say I think all right all right
um Chargers defense Ravens offense okay
when I went back and watched this game a
little bit and I know we talked about
this yesterday two things jumped out to
me okay I will say this three things
jumped out to me sorry the first one is
and we talked about it yesterday as the
Chargers defense Chargers defense was
not pushed around as much as I
remembered watching on TV or just
remembered in general
watching that football game yes there
was some moments where the Ravens gashed
them up the middle and everything but as
the game went on I mean the interior
offensive line for the Los Angeles
chargers played pretty damn good okay
and they really I mean I they played
very good they were not dominated in
fact I would say it was very close to a
stalemate as far as the run game goes
and that matchup which is crazy to say I
find it so genuinely warming that you
and your dad went and watched the game
and said well dad comb it my eyes have
deceived me yeah yeah I saw a different
game that actually existed well your TV
can lie right you just loosed active TV
of like what actually happened oh they
broke off a big run and you think oh
they're getting dominated you look after
the game ago oh well Lamar kept it
around the edge 420 they didn't really
nobody got like beat up or physically
killed right they just called the right
play or whatever
either way hey listen Baltimore's
offense and what they do it is tough to
deal with
but the Chargers I was encouraged
physically about what they did they keep
eight people at the line of scrimmage a
ton they tried to make a mess of things
at times to was stunts just to you know
kind of mess with the overall size of
the Ravens because they can't match up
always with the charger speed on the
defensive line but yes the Chargers hung
in there better against the power run
place and I gave them credit for the
other thing that jumped out to me is I
don't know why but I'm gonna say well
again is they watch that game I just
didn't realize how like Joey Bosa and
Melvin Ingram looked Orlando Browns but
a little bit more than I ever expected
and the pass game yes now they still got
Lamar Jackson wasn't game changing but
it be
we're Baltimore's gonna watch that film
this weekend go we can't leave our Lando
out there by himself all the time right
that's gonna be tough if only they had
four tight ends they could use yeah
exactly
so that are all six five 290 other thing
is there Darwin James factor and I think
this is a huge thing for the Chargers as
the game went on they always put Derwin
James to the side of the back and
shotgun right and why they were doing
that they were doing that for one reason
because they wanted to make sure durman
was there one-on-one with Lamar when he
kept the ball and I got that's that was
a big thing to me because German can
handle Lamar he's got enough speed so
you're telling me is on the right or the
running backs on the left
derman would shadow that so that if
there was an RPO he's has his eyes only
on the margins there to be that
contained guy to go okay there goes Gus
Edwards I'm on the side of the back I
know he's trying to go across the
formation and make me go there if he
does I'll get him right not I'm here for
Lamar
exactly right he's the only thing he's
gonna be there for Lamar and then once
he totally knows Lamar doesn't have the
ball which they're gonna tell him to be
like slow read it like when they say
slow read they're gonna be like
literally watch Lamar for their ease nod
your head and yeah right like really
make way to the ball right exactly then
you could go back to your cutback and
it's not just so rangy and athletic
right he'll be able to make a play I
would agree and they're gonna go listen
if the other ten guys don't stop them
before you then we [ __ ] up but we're
sure you're gonna get there after yes
exactly right so he's a x-factor in this
matchup just well that that made you
more confident even though it didn't
really work the first time well it did
when they started to do it there was
nothing much to it the whole go they did
not it kind of became a thing as the
game went on Lamar kept the ball a few
times and I look like they made a
conscious effort to go you know what
linebacker you bump in Derwin you stay
on the outside there and be there ready
for Lamar if he does keep it and I think
that will be something they will do once
again the other thing I think that I
should have said four things that jumped
out to me about this side of the matchup
I think the Chargers are probably gonna
watch back that film and go damn we
should have played more man-to-man and
Meikle
armed Jackson makes them throws what
were they playing on the market in
Jersey it's just your Seattle scheme
right there's like four guys chasing
exactly right it was all the underneath
guys and it was like they're just a you
know kind of all go and he crossed every
watch this game I thought about you with
this right why the [ __ ] are the Chargers
afraid of any of these receivers exactly
right right like it's like the Chiefs
weren't the week before remember I
watched it I went I haven't seen
Crabtree Sneed any of these guys make
one break and have more of more than a
yard gap right I didn't see a gap no I
know they weren't playing that much man
no they were not playing a lot of
man-to-man if they just manned up and
had Derwin spy I think that's what
you're gonna see more custom I would
imagine I would imagine they gonna go
we're gonna make Lamar Jackson make some
type throws he's not gonna get to like
anticipate it into a window this game or
throw a nice touch ball over the top to
the Andrews like you're talking about
you know so that's that side of the ball
okay now the other and so I do think
Lamar is going to have to be sharp in
this game for the Ravens to win this
game he's going to have to be sharp it's
not gonna be able to he's not gonna be
together way I don't think this time of
going like 13 for 24 for you know 195
yards that that's not good I don't think
that'll get it done
I really don't maybe I'm wrong now if I
flip it to the other side and when I
watch that things that jumped out to me
in this matchup but about the Ravens d
verse the Chargers offense first of
Ravens D is phenomenal they are one of
the few defenses in football that can
match up across the board man-to-man
when they want to and there are
Martindale's ability to dial up a blitz
right at the right situation or go
all-out blitz even against an
experienced quarterback like Phillip
Rivers since he doesn't do it a lot and
he calls it the right time it can catch
guys like Phillip Rivers but the big
thing would be this is and I know
there's no Melvin Gordon but Eckler yeah
or Eckler the interior line of the
Chargers is a little scary I mean it's a
little scary events these big [ __ ] we
know in Baltimore bright okay so that
scares me
um they scream game we see the Chargers
very good at screens like the Ravens
made it their point to go that's not
beating us like we're not gonna let
those cheap freakin plays ruin this game
for us so that
was taken away and Philip Rivers was as
flustered as I've ever seen him in the
last two years he was one I feel like a
little intimidated by the fact that damn
there's a lot of big people around me
all right and he was a little jumpy in
the pocket and I mean Philip Rivers is
almost never jumpy in the pocket first
half was super right and they took away
some of his easy throws I think a few
times he went to read one room too and
they weren't covered he goes oh my third
little shallow cross or something to be
open my late Trevor Williams they always
had a guy there whether they zone voice
or chargers yeah you're like every
Chargers pass play as a fan route I feel
like it's like one guy going deep one
guy going across and one guy underneath
they they do a lot of just feels like
every play they do and they mix it up
and do it that way with a lot of
different combinations but you're right
that's definitely a base premises of
what they do okay so that's another
thing
so I guess here's the last thing I'll
say to this just going back to a little
bit about the Ravens did on defense last
week and what I saw two against the
Browns the Ravens last week had a hard
time when the Browns went for receivers
to a side it could have been three
receivers to aside with the back also
offset off a Baker Mayfield to a side or
just four receivers to aside and it
messed up the Ravens rules a little bit
and Cleveland got a few completions and
the charges are a team that's more
capable right the charges do do that
they do it they can do four to the side
so I would think they look at that and
go we can tinker with that okay but I
guess the big thing I would say is I do
think it's good that Phillip Rivers and
this Ken wizard everybody got to see
this defense once before certainly and I
do think that Rivers either has to be
ultra tough or just have a really good
day of movement in the pocket if they
want to win this game okay so at the end
of the day I am going with the Los
Angeles chargers I'm only putting $10 on
it but I think the Chargers are gonna
win this game
22:17 oh don't I buy that little Raven
I know it's med for bugs that you you
will get charged the buck up you better
watch out 2017
top one tough one so I looked at I
rewatched that last game yeah obviously
yeah and a few things stuck out to me
that I thought were huge benefits to the
Ravens I thought one was the playing
surface in general I thought it was a
mess yeah and Baltimore just seemed
because they're a downhill running team
that it was their advantage the Chargers
were trying to cut a wide receivers were
falling all the time it was just too
much the other thing I think looking
back man
the Ravens got a lot of really big calls
yes they did there was an early
offensive pass interference on Keenan
Allen and then there was a huge catch by
Mike Williams and they called another
penalty on them there and then and then
one time Mike Williams was running on
the sideline they didn't call PI at all
I just thought that a lot of the calls
benefitted the Ravens yeah also to what
you were saying about the Lamar's gonna
have to make big plays right when I went
back and looked I forgot the last like
three drives of that game the Chargers
kind of figured out the Ravens offense
right and said Lamar you gotta beat us
yeah and if you remember right I believe
like two or three of those drives ended
in sacks in which Lamar was holding on
to the ball and was indecisive and
couldn't make a play yeah and I remember
thinking that game is the Chargers game
to win yeah they had a lot of big plays
they just had fumbles or dumb mistakes
you know Justin Tucker was able to hit a
few 50-yard bombers right I looked it up
in the wild-card round of the playoffs
John Harbaugh was five and Oh including
on the road with a rookie Joe Flacco
yeah John Harbaugh was made for this
[ __ ] he really is I also looked and
realized cuz I saw some people talking
about how Baltimore in the first half is
a pretty good bet all right in the last
three games the Chargers have only
scored 17 points in those first half's
combined meanwhile the Baltimore Ravens
have scored 36 points in the last first
half so it's an interesting bet to kind
of look at the Chargers have scored zero
points in five of their last eight first
quarters so the Chargers have
notoriously started slow
which is a very good game flow for a
Ravens team that's gonna want to
establish the run and get it started
early but in the end I looked at it and
I thought it's John Harbaugh and Lamar
versus Lynn and Whisenhunt vert and
Phillip Rivers I see the Ravens
controlling this game but I just don't
see this offense making it big enough to
stop Phillip Rivers on a mission and I
think at the end of the day the Phillip
Rivers mission is a more powerful force
in the ethos than the Lamar Jackson
mission is Yeah right and I'm taking the
Chargers 2219 because Justin Tucker is
gonna be kicking himself a lot of field
goals in this game and I'm putting $10
on the Chargers it just might be the
last time but it might be three more
times we don't know judge I believe that
equal and opposite reactions happen I
believe that if you go one way it's
gonna come back and I feel like the
Dallas Seattle game went everything in
Seattle's favor and I see it coming back
and I think that a lot of the stuff went
in Baltimore's favor I think that the
Chargers are a better team on the road
I could see Lamar starting this game off
a little bit kind of rusty and I do
think that the depth of the athletes on
the Chargers is gonna be enough yeah I
hear you it I mean I don't want to bet
against Phillip Rivers I couldn't either
there's too many unknowns and yeah you
got our young quarterback who and Lamar
Jackson who's still finding his way as a
thrower and in these type of situations
yeah I'm just going with Phillip Rivers
in this situation I do think it's this
is awesome I love the fact that this is
the third time or the second time
they're playing in three what makes it
so great because like in the NFL when
you play a team like that like fresh
still to remember
it really becomes more personal it
really does and these are you guys that
would take it personally member these
know Melvin ed to them on the field
they're gonna become mothers that mother
effer said this about me I'm armed hey
can we be real yeah we met out Melvin
Ingram oh I mean yes like do you know
what he's gonna be like in this game I
mean I think he wants to whoop you just
from the best friends episode still so
he's a nutjob right I'm in a good way oh
I mean perfect way I'm just been to end
quarterback sacker way I'm just checking
something really quick yes Phillip
Rivers I just looked up road playoff
games just out I'm just I'm not coming
with good or bad he's two and three
he lost his last one which was in 2014
at Denver mmm-hmm 17:24 he threw 217 two
touchdowns one interception the game
before that he was also on the road I
believe that was a wild card game he
beat Cincinnati 27 to 10 right 128 one
touchdown no interceptions and then he
went to Pittsburgh and threw 308 three
touchdowns one interception he's really
only had one bad road playoff game was
it the New England it was the new game
ACL so how about that yeah 211 to 2
interceptions no touchdown remember that
game that was Rivers and Brady stunk it
up in that game think about this is
Philip Rivers in the road in the
playoffs for his career that game he had
quarterback rating of 46 I think we can
all excuse him since he had a torn ACL
right his other four games these are as
quarterback ratings in descending
chronological order 1:16 119:105 133
yeah I know we don't put a lot of stock
in the quarterback okay there's
something to be said that's it's it's a
element you just take to you know make
some points and and just yeah there's
things to be taken from us I'm with you
all right guys ready yeah so why did we
feel comfortable taking the quarterback
there over a Russell Wilson it's just
the overall team yeah I think it's the
overall team right I don't
I'm not dak Prescott it's a little more
advanced than Lamar Jackson so that's
what I would say there gotcha
yeah and he's been in the playoffs
before right and he's in his 34th year
all right guys final game of the weekend
here Sunday afternoon I just made
that is me 4:40 on Sunday afternoon the
Chicago Bears hosting the Philadelphia
Eagles spread in this game is Chicago -
six weather in Chicago on Sunday 41 as
the high and it will be cloudy yeah yeah
that's not too bad and what's the Windy
what's the wind and say 13 miles per
hour
out of the east not gonna affect much
there okay so that's cool that's you
know sunrise 7:18 a.m. and then well so
this is gonna be a night game so what's
the low for the day would you say it was
low is 39 rain late in the afternoon oh
geez who does that help
check that periods of rain after
midnight so no rain okay thank you
weatherman thank you Sam champion ok
sunset for 34 p.m. oh it's gonna be dark
right around kickoff okay so Eagles
bears let's go with the Eagles offense
versus bears defense but how does he
play and this doesn't count as prime
time cuz it's not kickoff after 7
o'clock even though it's the biggest
game of his life it's not prime time all
playoff games prime time I think all
games in the NFL or prime time don't I
think any quarterback goes Thanksgiving
noon is also prime time yes I think
everybody thinks every game is prime
time ok all right so the Eagles offense
you know what really [ __ ] up your
whole theory on that Kirk Cousins
pregame speech about flex scheduling
what he said you were like every game is
prime time and Kurt's like do you know
why they moved us to the 8:30 slot on
Sunday at NBC because were the Vikings
right it was like what are you doing
what are you the TV guy yeah no I know
and well he also had to answer comments
that week about playing in primetime and
he said in every game is his name so ok
but you know he was channeling his inner
Josh in that speech right
the Eagles offense verse the Bears
defense Bears defense is the best in the
NFL for my money I know that's debatable
with the Raider I mean the Ravens and
the Cowboys and all them but if you may
me pick one defense I am going with the
Chicago Bears as my defense this is
where I think the Eagles pose problems
for Chicago I mean left go as you know
the Eagles offensive line is healthy
right and
they're big I mean they're big you know
Kelsey and Wisniewski are not real big
big guys I get that but Brandon Brooks
Lane Johnson and Peters I mean those are
some big mofos right there okay but
either way with it being healthy and a
hundred percent everybody across the
board for the most part the old line has
improved it's been better in pass
protection and you've heard me complain
that they've been running the ball up
the middle but more right which you know
it annoys me they hadn't done that all
year there's definitely been more
attention to running up the middle I do
even feel like Nick Foles has been under
the center a little bit more which I do
like that for the Philadelphia offense
it gives the up the middle run game a
little more you know what do I want to
say it just sells it a little bit more
and it helps with play-action passes
right so I I look at all those things my
big thing is this I don't really think
fill it up is gonna really run the ball
in Chicago like I just don't sure don't
see Wendel Smallwood and Josh Adams no I
don't but what I would say is this don't
stop running it just because don't be
afraid to be in third and two and third
and three like we said in the other
podcasts the one thing I admire about
Philadelphia lately as they have not
been scared to go third in twos great
situation for us where most teams in the
NFL went out and like second and nine
and they go we need to throw for 10
yards right here and then it's third and
nine and Philadelphia has been very
patient ago Oh second and nine will
throw a screen and we'll run or but
throw another short pass and getting
sacked third and three and then the
defense doesn't know what we're gonna do
it's screen throw Sproles around the
edge on a wheel route you know hurts
over the middle of you're screwed you're
at their behest
so I want them to run the ball just to
keep the Bears honest and to help your
play-action passes now the real
advantage you have and to me this is
where the games gonna come down to is
can the Philadelphia Eagles do a little
bit what they did last week and can they
and dunk the Chicago Bears can they you
know three yards here five yards here
six yards here their tribes were like
all over ten minutes long yeah they were
forever it was here on the field for
like three quarters it was a slow death
it was slow death and now the one thing
I'll say is this after watching the
Bears defense yesterday and you heard me
say this is they were all over the
Vikings
the bear the Vikings had crossover
concepts because that was de Filippo who
was from Philadelphia so of course he
had some of the same things there's
nobody who runs more shallow crossers or
the guy ten yards over the middle and
turned to the quarterback than the
Philadelphia Eagles and I would also say
there is nobody better at defending
those plays than the Chicago Bears now
they also got to see the Vikings do that
last
the Vikings do that last week and saw
how the Bears defend it so maybe they
have a few wrinkles ready for it this
time around but that only definitely
something I watch for it the other thing
I'll say this about Nick Foles and he's
better at this than Carson Wentz and
I'll give him this and I was kind of
saying this and on the NBC show didn't
this morning they actually I said it
yesterday and they had a graphic that
backed it up so again I always feel good
when I say things that I'm seeing with
my naked eye that I'm not charging a
good way to qualify and unqualified say
exactly right and his ability like we've
talked about to throw with people around
him and pressure because he's a big guy
it is impressive it was there like a
next-gen step first impact Nick Foles is
first in passer rating what he's hit as
he throws yes when he's under pressure
or hurried right he's phenomenal the
numbers bear it out it's really funny we
marvel at Carson Wentz's ability to
escape right we have we marvel at Nick
Foles ability to not be able to escape
but just get smashed once just goes let
me see where I get thrown right I'll
throw it where when sits there and goes
I think I can make this guy miss and
they break this tackle and then I see
that 50 yarder coming down all I got
sacked oh darn it you know that's what
happens that's the difference there
Foles knows I'm not gonna be able to do
all that I better just find a safe place
to throw this ball as I'm getting hit
and he's good at placing the ball
correctly so that's thing I will look
for can they dink and dunk the Chicago
Bears I would say no but I don't feel
great about that
okay I'll just say that much now the
Bears overs the Eagles D you know the
strength of your D we talked about this
a million times as your defensive line
you know the Bears old line is very good
it really is and they're healthy then I
have a hard time thinking that your D
defensive line can steamroll that bunch
and that's what worries me about your
secondary a little bit because Nagy is a
pretty creative game planner I don't
want him to waste all his good
plays in the first 10 minutes of the
game which he is a habit of doing life
repairs
I mean it's every game he's got every
game it's like wow wow wow and then the
second and third quarter or I know he
almost has to put a ticket three hours
out of his life this week and come up
with a you know first 15 for the second
half to like almost do something like
that or have things you save for the
second half which is what like a Doug
Peterson or Andy Reid do where they go
yeah we love these plays but I'm gonna
save these for for the second half right
so that I look at that
the Bears do have great balance I worry
about your secondary if you guys can't
get pressure just because one they do
have good physical weapons and two they
have a well-rounded pass attack now true
brisk ease ability to consistently hit
the rose is going to be certainly a
question mark for me
in the football game in general and the
other thing would be this and you've
heard me say this it's hard to play
man-to-man against the Chicago Bears or
you better be careful because Mitchell
troub risky will run the ball Mitchell
true Biscay is arguably the best
scrambling quarterback in the NFL I mean
I would say Josh Allen's one yes okay
but he's in there with Lamar and deshaun
Watson and all those guys right I mean
it's pretty special what he does there I
would like us a lot of good mobile
quarterbacks right there is I would like
to see the Bears be a little bit more
aggressive with their downfield passing
game because I do feel like teams kind
of get a feel for them and they start to
squat on things um and the other thing
that scares me about Mitchell
Stravinsky's running is man your your
pass rush is so undisciplined I mean
you're you know yeah it's gym shorts and
you got a bunch of meatheads and we just
gotta make a packet I don't care if none
of you were in the same gap as long as
we get them it's okay well that could be
good until who are the best pass rushers
for the Eagles right now from your
estimation um like Fletcher Cox
obviously yeah but rocks is the most
limit line has come along lately long
looks better lately Michael Bennett
looks like a force Michael Bennett's the
best pass rusher so this offseason I
went on to a radio show that said that
Michael Bennett was old in the tooth and
I said the thing that you're not
realizing is the man played almost 900
snaps a year from Seattle right and now
he's coming into a team where he doesn't
have to and my hope before the season
was at this point of the year yeah
Bennett would be fresher at this point
of the year than he ever has been yeah
sure they were not rotating him in
Seattle no not to the sixth and if
they're gonna have a chance
he needs to be ecstatic but look where
has Brandon Graham gone no I've been
underwhelming the whole year that's why
they're excited to let him go and same
with Chris long it was underwhelming the
whole year so other than them who's
there yeah Hector guy you like he does a
good job certainly it's it's been just
an improvement all together by Oliver I
don't know if Chris long has had an
injury issue or whatever but no I mean I
don't think I'm missing anybody there as
far as that group that I just wanna say
I don't think it's that great of a pass
rushing it's not last year that's what
everyone I want to tell people the Bears
are you guys last year right that's what
I keep trying to tell people but nobody
can see it cuz folds this quarterback
and it's just like no word last year and
we're here again and I want to go no the
Bears are really what you guys were last
year okay so that's where I just look at
that a little bit but I guess that does
concern me and I don't know if there was
another point I wanted to make on that
side of the ball but I guess I'll just
get to the point and I am putting $10 on
the Chicago Bears yes I am going to pick
the Bears to win this game 24 to 17
which covered the six point spread I
would not be shocked if the Bears really
made like I wouldn't be shocked the
Bears won this game 24 10 either now of
course you know I mean my friend he's in
Chicago
Danny Park and he's a cog Oh radio host
price to me 24 1024 10 yeah I mean I
said what's your squinty to 10 24 to 10
but I don't know I am still scared of
the Eagles cuz you're the Superbowl
chance and you do have belief and Nick
Foles has belief and that scares me
that's why I won't bet a lot of money on
this game I get it yeah I wrote down
copious notes
I felt other pages for all the other
games I wrote one sentence yeah
Philadelphia wins and I have no freaking
idea how so leave me alone I'm a fan
I'm putting $10 in the Philadelphia okay
they'll go in to Chicago Nick Foles his
back look how long his thing keeps goes
my I really just want to like ask you
questions about this guy let's go
because like I cannot pick Eagles games
to save my life I just have no idea but
I think the reason I have hope is we're
up against a quarterback that's never
playing the playoff fair and a coach
that's never been in the playoffs with a
quarterback that pulled off incredible
feats and your stat like I'm used
stealing that number one passer rating
under pressure that's unbelievable
that's what you have to have to beat the
Bears for me my hope on offense is I
hope they bring out the trick place I
hope that Doug Peterson that they keep
out coaching themselves because of
Carson Wentz yeah and it's a lot of
smart trick plays trick plays that we
haven't seen before we're talking Philly
specials like whipping them out in this
game I don't care I'm talking about flea
flickers like Nelson Aguilar
I don't want necessarily the screens
because I think Chicago's so fast
they'll sniff those out personally I'd
like to tack attack Prince Amukamara I
believe that I don't think he's as shut
down as as maybe he's being able to know
he made know I also the guy that I fear
the most of the Bears offense
is Taylor Gabriel sure because I am
afraid of the deep shots I'm not
necessarily afraid of Alan Robinson it's
gonna suck when Tirico and makes big
plays I don't think Jordan Howard's
gonna have that big of a game I really
hope the Bears try and force it but my
hope is that that the Bears make
mistakes
we are outclassed as a team I'm thrilled
that it's not a super cold game because
I don't believe Nick Foles plays that
great in the cold but I also think that
you know if if it doesn't start off
great for true Biscay we got a chance
yeah because that dude can get into his
own head
start sailing some balls and and I've
been impressed lately with Avante Maddox
I've been impressed with some of the
secondary members I thought like LeBlanc
has like played pretty well these last
few weeks yeah some of the linebackers
coming back look nigel Bradham in a big
game is fun to watch that man can make
things happen but one big Fletcher Cox
hit we're in this game yeah sure and I I
would just say don't let your again
something we always say about your team
and you've been really good about it
late cuz your front four has been
playing better is just don't put your
guys in the back end and compromising
don't give Mitchell Tripp risky to get
out of jail free card with Nigel Brad a
man-to-man on Tariq Owen and a wheel
route you know those are the things I
would you rather attack Mitchell try
risky or would you rather contain I
would rather contain I think you'd
almost play Mitchell a little bit like
you want the Chargers to play Lamar yes
I would I would contain and I would go I
gotta see him
execute and make decisions and make
accurate throws which we know are some
of the question marks about him yeah I
would make him do that next q then if
you go okay damn it's been two drives in
a row and he's on today and he's then
you have to change things up but that
would be something I would go as an
Eagles defensive coach I do I gotta see
that first to believe it because for me
the thing that scares me that the Bears
is a little bit what you said about the
Eagles I'm afraid of the crossers yeah
I'm afraid of the underneath I'm afraid
of the setups for the Tariq Cowen's and
all those guys and all that but I'm not
necessarily as afraid of Mitch going
deep
right I'm just afraid of the Taylor
Gabriel if he does catch the one deep
ball yeah right
because if Taylor Gabriel catches the
one deep ball and gets that touchdown I
don't really feel that great yeah and
I'll tell you what I really feel great
about facing Cody park II like scary
like the Bears are a team that could
push the Eagles around for 12 plays in
80 yards and settle for that 34 yard
field goal and we get all the momentum
back and you know what else this is the
truth cuz this is a fan hood thing who
did you just say the Bears are fails the
Eagles
it's funny to look back at that Eagles
Falcons game now
Falcons come in alright divisional game
yeah and all of the pressure was on Nick
Foles if you remember what we were
saying back then he had just come off an
awful game where he played like a half
against the Cowboys he had an awful game
against the Raiders and the talk in that
game was if it starts going south for
Nick Foles
Philadelphia is going to freak out
because it's like oh no we're letting go
of all of this good stuff it's wasting
away all of our fears are coming true if
you don't believe that Bears fans are
gonna poop a brick if Mitchell try
Biscay starts slow if you don't think
that you're gonna start hearing some
whispers and some boos in the second
quarter one of our producers karen is a
huge Bears fan and a lot of Bears fans
right now are feeling really cocky you
know gets scared the most the people
that have been cocky all week the Eagles
are going in with no fear they're
already dead to rights
they shouldn't be here and also if
they're down 14 guess what they're used
to it they were dead they were getting
their ass kicked by the Falcons before
they turned it around you know who's not
used to coming from behind the Bears if
this goes bad in the beginning I am I'm
telling you Bears fans will eat
themselves inside out they will be so
consumed with fear because this is their
beautiful season they want to protect
this is it and the crazy thing about the
team of destiny is that that [ __ ]
changes sides quick it does and if you
start getting in with fear you do
doesn't have fear the team of destiny
I'm just saying like I know this is me
kind of pumping myself up definitely I
can art if you guys go down 14 nothing
you're gonna get blown the [ __ ] out to
your right yeah I mean blown out there
but would you agree with me that if true
Biscay is not good early yeah Chicago is
gonna sound like a great it's gonna make
all of them play tight all of them gonna
go man
it's a bad Mitch game it's a bad Mitch
gear yeah and then then they're gonna
lose game integrity what happens what
did you think of that whole thing I just
did III don't even know what you just
did right there you just flustered
yourself up to match the color of your
sweatshirt with your cheese no but
seriously
no but seriously I mean listen you got a
sense no no it's not nonsense you guys
are scary
you definitely are this is the best
defense you guys have played all year
okay that's what I like scheme wise and
player wise it's a double whammy the
second time all year like you'll bail
Mac has been the second best offensive
player on the field but there Burt
you've been protecting awesome late
laser bolts and that's a yes that is a
bold statement but I am gonna be yes
you've been protecting great lately all
right that's the big thing we just pick
your brain react which defensive lineman
typically are on the right guard and the
right tackle for the Bears for the right
guard and the right tackle players who's
usually over the right guard and right
tackle you talk about the Bears defense
you're asking me sorry um well it just
depends on the formation itself but
you're gonna have Eddie Goldman or
Hakeem Hicks over your your guards right
that's where any books will do it will
destroy ya I mean Brandon Brooks should
be fine with any any other matchups I
mean brightener Brooks for me is one of
the better guards in football you know
anything was I Lane Johnson who's Lane
Johnson battling
yeah well that could be a number of
people there's Khalil am I facing
Peter's merge or he moves around but
even probably see Peters more
yes he's guarding hurts you could have
found a row quad yeah or it could be it
could be one of the safeties and then
Eddie Jackson if he's healthy or a mouse
or somebody like abs matching up with
but that was great they don't play a ton
of man-to-man you know that's why there
are big range Sean yeah nobody I mean I
think nobody's gonna leap without Sean
they don't have that size they're
Fuller's their best cover corner that's
for sure he can lock down Jeffery but is
he gonna catch break up to 50/50 balls
no that'll be will we see that on Sunday
are you the most confident that the
Bears are gonna win or you're the most
government that the Cowboys are gonna
win the Cowboys okay yeah you guys are
not like you know you you match up okay
with the Bears you do I mean there's
there's no doubt about that there's some
scary things there for the Chicago Bears
and I
just want to say this to clear my
conscience yeah the Eagles making the
playoffs he's already a successful
season to me and the reason I say this
is this when they lost the Saints by a
million everything that week was is this
the worst team after a Super Bowl ever
we've never seen a team Super Bowl team
get beat like this before there's been
countless Super Bowl teams that have not
even made the playoffs yeah and for the
Eagles to come back they surprised me
it's a testament to them I love this
team and Chris Long vs Kyle long is my
favorite matchup of that game yeah Kyle
long has already come out and said I
don't even know that guy all right guys
recapping the bets from this week
Indiana you guys are both going with
Indy Sims you have 580 on it left go you
have 10 on it Seattle at Dallas you are
both going with Dallas - 1.5 Sims you
have a thousand on it left go you have
15 70s change my Colts won and put all
of it on the tech Dallas Cowboys LA at
Baltimore's
one would what I have been able to
change it right once you say it verbally
that's over locked in oh yeah if you
decided right before on the podcast I've
said that live changes are allowed right
changed this is a classic Sims move of
just trying to put that in my brain that
maybe I thought really happened was Josh
sent that text saying how much money do
you guys have and then he later texted
me and said
however I will say it would be cool if
one of you happen to put 15 70 and I
already had the email in my inbox going
Dallas 15 said you know what
oh well then maybe you like this oh
you're talking about today okay Elliot
Baltimore Baltimore - 2.5 you're both
going with LA for ten bucks and
Philadelphia at Chicago spread is
Chicago - six Sims you're taking the
Bears for ten bucks left go you were
taking the Eagles for 10 bucks sorry I
swore so much today I'm just excited
it's playoff football it deserves a few
squares I agree yeah it's tough ball
where will you be watching the game
Saturday I'll be at my house yeah and
then Sunday you're gonna be your pregame
be in the pregame what time is that
start - four o'clock it's like a
30-minute pregame show so let's give it
a little behind the scenes when you're
on TV at 4:00
what time do you get there I will be
there probably by 12:30 yeah I know
you're gonna watch the other game yeah I
mean usually we have to be there by like
12 or 12:30 when the games at 8 o'clock
at night so I'm I'm not getting there
earlier than that I know that
where are you watching the games
probably on my couch okay
certainly not joining not with you why I
may be with you maybe not the Eagles
game I might watch Saturday with you
okay I never know how to watch Eagles
games I'm a mess yeah I'm gonna watch at
home not sure we watch it together
though right
Falcons Eagle we routed forward together
thank God for kion O'Neal's knee gave me
a Super Bowl that's crazy for Simms
peace out homies for fendron good
evening everybody and I am the lef koe
man we will holla holla holla holla
holla atcha later hopefully on Monday
Tuesday we're talking about the Eagles
beef hopefully not